sur l'île de nosy komba deux tiers des
habitants cultivent la précieuse booth à
l'ombre d'une forêt tropicale
dans ce climat chaud et humide la
vanille est prête pour la récolte
neuf mois après la fécondation des
fleurs par la main de l'homme le bout
des gousses doit être jeune et on voit
bien ici qui n'est plus vert mais qu'il
se rapproche plutôt de la couleur de la
banane veine ans a planté ses premières
lianes de vanille alors que les prix
continuaient de grimper en 2017
il lui a fallu attendre deux ans pour
que les premières gouttes naissent en
il a pu vendre son premier sac de 9 kg
sur le marché sa récolte sera trois fois
plus importante cette année on fait très
attention
le produit est très cher les rumeurs
évalue le prix du kilo de vanille verte
cette année à 300 mille francs malgache
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais en
tout cas l'année dernière il se vendait
à un million de francs
les planteurs s'attendent à une baisse
drastique des prix avant même de quitter
la forêt pour le marché les acheteurs
des collecteurs revendeurs ou
exportateur affluent par bateau vers le
village dans diab et ce marché de
vanille et le plus important de tout
l'archipel de nocibé c'est dans le
nord-ouest du pays que les premières
gouttes malgaches sont récoltés chaque
année au moment où on parle les
planteurs sont encore à leurs récoltes
d'erding est tombé lloris ils vont venir
ici et le marché dépend de sa les ventes
ne peuvent se faire pendant la nuit
donc si on voit que l'on ne peut pas
bouclé aujourd'hui on terminera demain
[Musique]
dès les premières ventes le ton est
donné
entre 15 et 20 euros le kilo pour la
bouffe verte elle perd plus de 60% de sa
valeur par rapport à la précédente
campagne
quand on on voir les plis rayman 3 à 4
fois moins cher a créé il ya des trois
années passées
ça fait mal j'espère à quai l'année
prochaine c'est fini la couronne a dit
rice tout ça là je pense là les prix
doivent stable stabiliser les prix
c'est l'effet recherché par une
réglementation renforcée cette année
pour éviter la spéculation
le vol des gousses et favoriser le
retour de la qualité l'état a mis en
place une série de décrets dates heures
et lieux des transactions sont encadrées
par les autorités locales sous étroite
surveillance des forces de l'ordre le
marché ne sera pas
éternel il y a une limite de six rondes
il de marché durera de chou ces deux
shows rien que dans ce village de moins
de 2000 habitants
six tonnes de vanille verte ont été
vendues en deux jours la filière qui
compte deux cent mille acteurs à
madagascar produit vend et exporte en
moyenne 1700 tonnes de vanille à travers
le monde chaque année
avec 80% de la production mondiale
madagascar reste le leader incontesté
c'est ici que se dessinent les tendances
pour les prix à l'exportation à la
baisse cette année
le kilo de vanille noir devrait en
théorie lui aussi se vendre deux à trois
fois moins cher qu'en 2019